hey friends how's it going welcome back
to the deep dive snippet in this little
clip i'm speaking to will store the
author of the best-selling book of the
status game and in this little clip he
and i are talking about that given that
we know that ultimately we're all
fundamentally motivated by the chase and
the desire for social status how can we
use that concept to end up being more
likeable at work and in our day-to-day
lives and through the people that we
come across now this is not a video clip
about the science of manipulating people
for your nefarious ends or anything like
that it's literally a guide on how to
understand human motivation and
therefore use that to be more likeable
at work if that's what you're into
anyway let's roll the clip there was an
an interesting chapter where we talked
about sort of the uh
the sort of the
the real life cues that we give off when
we are higher status or lower status
and i wonder like often you know we did
a survey for the podcast and people said
that they like getting actionable tips
that they can apply in their work life
yeah i was kind of thinking that like
are there actionable tips that you can
apply in your work life for example
knowing knowing that the status game
exists
in every every relationship you're gonna
have at work for example yeah i think i
i think so you know what one of the
things i think is really important is is
in in the business context is to always
have that understanding that you're
never the hero in other people's stories
they're always the hero they're always
the one on this great pursuit of status
which their brain remixes as this kind
of heroic you know pursuit
and so so it's much better in the
business context to come across as um
the kind of that like you're a helpful
person in their story yeah so there's a
story scholar who i think is really
smart guy called christopher booker who
wrote a book called the seven basic
plots it's like a huge like two thousand
word
two thousand page thing i think it's
like huge um
he writes about um this archetypal
figure in story called the light figure
and and the exhaust and the light figure
is like um the light doesn't light yeah
exactly the light figure and the light
figures come into the story and they're
like the ghost in the christmas carol
yeah their job is there to help scrooge
become heroic to see the area of idea
and so i think in the business context
if you go in there boast boasting i'm
amazing you want to work with me i'm
fantastic you're going to put people off
because you're not the hero they're the
hero yeah so you're much better off
being the light figure and your story is
this is how i'm going to help you gain
status i'm going to do these things to
help you and so that's the first thing
and then the second thing is is about
impression management
so um you know there's lots of sciences
looked at looked at how do we how
socially do we give a good impression to
other to other people
and
for a long time
they
talked about two domains warmth and
competence and more recently it's been
argued that there's a there should be a
third domain out of that which is
morality
and when i was reading about this it
really struck me because in the book i
write about those three status games
there's dominance which is the
aggressive animalistic status game
there's virtue and their success and
those three they called them warmth
competence and morality but i i called
it warmth confidence and sincerity okay
you map on perfectly to those three
status games yeah so i don't i don't
know but i don't think that's a
coincidence you know i i i think that
that that
that it's interesting that those map
onto those um three stages games so well
and the logic is when you approach
somebody with warmth what you're
subconsciously signaling to that person
is that i'm not going to um compete for
status with dominance with you i'm not
going to threaten you i'm not going to
coerce you i'm not going to
use physical violence against you you
know so we're going to have a healthy
um
non-aggressive status game when you're
signaling with sincerity
you're saying i'm going to play a good
virtue game with you which is i'm going
to be um you know morally respectable it
does not mean i'm going to suck up to
you i'm not going to give you [ __ ]
i'm going to tell you the truth and when
i'm not happy i'm going to tell you i'm
not happy so i'm going to be sincere you
know i'm always going to be honest with
you and then finally competence if you
if you come across as a competent person
you are
you are signaling not only am i going to
be useful to our out
not only am i going to be useful to our
our our group our game but you know you
also might learn some stuff from me so
there are there are things that i can do
and if you learn how to do them from me
you're also going to raise in status
yeah so i think if you if you can it's
obviously easier said than done but but
if you can if you can manifest in those
three ways warmth sincerity and
competence yeah it's very hard to know
how you're going to fail in life
you know and you know you can't just
come across in those ways you've got to
actually live those ideals you've got to
be sincere you've got to be
non-aggressive yeah and you've got to be
competent you've got to be good at your
you know you've got to be good at the
thing that you're doing hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day